we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] had peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
hey hey folks here we are we might be
drunk we're here we're queer and sam's
making some cheer we got sam morell on
the blower and our pal you know him you
love him chrissy d
krista stefano chrissy bit chips call
him what you will how are you chris
what's up everybody how you doing you
look sharp you look sexy
yeah but you know it is here's the slime
i am it's like you think that it's like
this nice you know you know expensive
outfit the jackets from h m the jeans
are all navy and i'm wearing a budweiser
shirt so i just couldn't i'm all about
hiding it you look like yeah i'm hardy
or some [ __ ] really yeah you look good
as [ __ ] i think tom hardy's the i think
here's what i'll say about tom hardy
he's the actor because you know everyone
says like oh if i was drunk like i'd
hook up with this guy even though i'm
not gay like tom hardy's the closest
guy hook up with where i'm not drunk i
wouldn't need right i'd so i do it sober
in front of my family
i'd kiss him on the left you know yeah
oh look at this so what's sam making a
martine
yeah we're doing a cloudy martini i got
this is amazon these were free and i
stole this from uniqlo so i'm with you
did you steal it yeah i don't know what
this but what i'm wearing that's nice
too
it fits like a goddamn glove it's kind
of tight lanky scarecrow body again
there it is look at this studio yeah not
too shabby huh i like it i like that i
came in uh and the the front the doorman
guy told me i didn't have to wear a mask
i was like i'm sorry i have a mask he's
like it's okay man that's how we do it
here yeah
oh there it is nice dude this looks like
my dad's urine
that's a dangerfield joke i was drinking
so much i pissed an olive yeah you could
just tell no disrespect oh i could just
tell this is going to suck
take a second
you'll feel better than it tastes
there we go
sam i stand corrected
[ __ ] what sam what i literally stand f
wow i thought this this because this
looks like sewage because you know why
because it's actual good ass brine wow
dude this is amazing this looks like
what happened to the the mississippi
river in louisiana this is no i know
this looks like early this is hurricane
katrina exactly
but um
it's like a meal dude there's so much
olive juice in here it's like it's like
a meal i'm getting calories in here it
looks like a like a la hot chick drink
yeah it tastes like my dad yeah no i
know i mean it's just it tastes
delicious
yeah norman's got a hot dog sound like
my stepmom
oh are your parents divorce mark no no i
wish they're still together and they go
at it my parents are divorced and i was
speaking to my dad my dad's uh visiting
uh me from florida he's been saying this
for two weeks and he said you know the
best thing i ever did in my life was
divorce your mother he's like i'm sorry
like that if that hurts you he's like
but really like you wouldn't be
i wouldn't be proud of you if i was
still married to your mom he's like yeah
he was like he just think because he was
just like my life was going nowhere with
your mom he's like and your mom's a good
person and i'm a good person but we just
weren't good together and i think that
the best thing i ever did was divorce
her he goes he goes and you know 37
years later i'm so he said i would never
be as happy as i am as a human being if
i was still married to your mom i'm with
the louis ck is that great joke every
when he got divorced i was like i'm
sorry he's like no divorce is great it's
the best thing you can because i bet you
somebody like louie or anybody like you
know when it's not like the divorce came
out i know where he was probably waiting
to do that or guys you're waiting to do
that for years and then when it finally
happens you're like
yeah i'm out of jail kind of thing you
know it's a weird thing it is weird to
tell you like i'm i'm a bet i wouldn't
be proud i'm happy i get right i
wouldn't be proud as a little that's a
happy well what he was saying was what
he was saying was he was like
he said because because he said i think
that i was able to be like a good dad to
you because i was not in a negative
headspace with because i was not with
your mom if i was with your mom he said
i would have just been a miserable
curmudgeon of a guy and then you
probably would have turned out like a
big piece of [ __ ] right and so he was
like you know you i think you're a happy
guy right because my dad was like i'm
happy but i i could only get happy when
i left your mom yeah because she sucks
i've had both your parents
my mom and dad how about this my mom and
dad
they now are like actual like friends
again but that's it's only because i
started to have kids like before i had
kids they would fight anything they got
into a fight in the crowd at my david
letterman set where i saw if you watch
my david letterman said about whatever
it is three and a half minutes in i like
look up a little bit because there was a
some commotion yeah and then mad dog
matter and james madden was sitting he
was one of my guests to come and he was
sitting up there he goes yeah he goes
that commotion the ushers ran down the
aisle and almost threw your mom and dad
up because your mom was sitting in like
the center seat and my dad your dad
leaned over
and was like hey you weren't never at
any of his shows i should be in the
center no not you and then she was like
i was the one that was at all the open
mics he goes he goes i was the one who
was at the maui taco i was the one who
did all that he goes i went to the creek
in the cave he was like you didn't do
any of that and she was like shut up
tony he's on stage who gives it and then
because james gets your closer i know i
know
mad dog manner and was sitting in
between the both of them so my james was
the buffer between my dad and my mom
james i know i would say this if i'm
your therapist they're making your
letterman spot about them they got to be
there for you right there i know i know
and then my mom ran down the stairs and
pretty practically pushed me out of the
way so you get a picture with john
travolta he was the other guest
you talked to travolta right yo no
listen the thing is with a guy
with a guy like a john travolta somebody
i know just met tom cruise and said that
like there's an aura to them like like
you understand why they're famous like
there's something magical and tim dillon
said the same about alec baldwin
just worked did something with alec
baldwin
you get he did his podcast said you get
why he's so famous travolta has that
thing where it's like it's a presence
that i i don't have we don't have you
know so it's like so they have it where
you're like oh i get why hollywood was
attracted to this person and why they're
like this this is something otherwise
because he had me in one of his trances
that's what they do he had me in a
[ __ ] trance i saw him
i was going up next you know he had just
finished his segment and there's like
that commercial break and i'm standing
there by that curtain you know waiting
to go out i could see the set i'm like
[ __ ] myself and he walks past me and
then he comes back he goes whoa you have
on a beautiful suit and i was like yeah
i was like i was like i go it's from
joseph a bank and he was like oof and
then
he kind of he was like oh you know and i
was like i bought it off the rack in
suffolk county long island a day before
because
i don't know if you remember remembering
the taylor remember like out of our
group like of guys who like started like
che was the first one to get like
letterman and everyone's like he wore
jeans right and then i was like oh [ __ ]
i was going up two weeks later i was
like i gotta get a suit yeah i don't own
a suit right so so i so i just bought
this [ __ ] suit that was too big and
he goes um he goes this is you have such
a beautiful suit and i was like wow i
was like thanks and then he goes um he
goes uh he goes so so are you nervous
and i was like a little bit and then he
put his hand on my chest like without
like just put his hand like right in the
middle of my chest he goes why is your
heart beating so fast i was like because
you have your hand on my nipple that's
his pickup line yeah yeah and then he
goes and then he goes and then he goes
um he goes just calm down breathe with
me and i was like what i swear to god
dude this my mother's witnessing this
whole thing
he goes i know oh 100
he goes he goes wit you know he goes um
he goes just breathe with me and i was
like okay and he goes you've done this
already and i said no i haven't i'm
going up next he goes you've done this
already and i go no i'm going up i
almost like i almost like got angry
because yeah you're anxious i almost was
like no [ __ ] stupid i'm next like yes
i'm i'm paralyzed with fear right now
yes so i put my and he goes no you've
done this already and i said wow i
haven't he goes no no you have because
your set had to be vetted i'm sure by
david letterman and all his bookers and
producers i'm sure they don't just let
you on so you've done this set you've
practiced the famous people think that
letterman is watching ourselves yeah
yeah yeah yeah david was like thanks
frank like he didn't give a [ __ ] conan
o'brien's in the room like that guy
right there yeah that's not how it
happened so there's a booker but he says
to me he goes um he goes uh you've done
it already you've been vetted producers
they don't just let anyone on the show
he was like so it's the hard part our
next guest paul mercurio yeah
i know he goes you know what's so crazy
dude dude um the guy who's the guy eddie
braille who is the warm-up comic did one
of my bits that i was later gonna do in
the water on the letterman show in the
warm-up james i had all these texts from
james madden you know i don't dare look
at my phone sure all these texts from
james madden hey man don't do the r word
bit don't do the r word bit that i i i
oh i'm not r word but a bit where i add
ours into words that don't need ours he
was doing it based off like a boston
actor you used to call it the n word bit
yeah exactly i love joe rogan yeah i'm
starting a podcast with neil young it's
called we both never did rogue
i'll be a guest yeah there you go
so so joni mitchell there it is so so um
you know he's like you've done this
already and i said no i have it whatever
he goes no no you all the hours all the
times you practice in front of the
mirror the hard part is done you've been
selected now you just have to go live
the moment so it's over already the work
is done it's over just go live the five
minutes wrong and he goes be present for
those five minutes that's my only advice
to you goes and you know what he goes
i'm supposed to catch a flight i want to
stay here and watch you live this moment
he said it's so cool for me to see
someone experience this for the first
time he goes i'm going to be here
cheering on you're going to crush great
job and i'm like holy smokes and then
with that like almost like while he's
talking you know i don't realize that
about 90 seconds i've went by you get
that little tap on your shoulder because
you can't hear and they tap me out and i
hear david letterman saying please
welcome chris stephanie my god and i
went out there and i had you know like a
really good present you get the moment
set and i felt like oh my god and in my
head this whole time i'm thinking like
i'm like doing these jokes in front of
john travolta like who knows what could
happen maybe i'll be talking
i don't know and then i come out and i
see my mom there and she's like oh my
god like you know like great whatever
how's it feel i was like amazing and i
was like where's where's john
and she goes oh honey he left
immediately i swear to god
yeah
but he did what he had to do he got you
truthfully yeah and i almost wasn't mad
i said i said mom how quick did he like
you mean after the first joke she goes
no as soon as you
went on to stage and said and put your
hand up to wave hello he walked out yeah
so so it was but i'm not mad at him at
all
about that at all nothing you had a
moment with him and now you're a
scientologist and then i swear to god
and then you're ready for this and this
is a thousand percent true the ve we we
know this as comics but the audience may
not know it's like we want to hurt
ourselves a lot so i had a set at the uh
david letterman i felt fantastic i then
immediately took the bus
took the bus
with james madden and my ex-girlfriend
at the time and my friend from home took
the bus to the village lantern yeah okay
the old village lantern comedy club and
i bombed with that same set in front of
six or seven swedish people in my
letterman suit i just was like i have to
do it i did i drank a 40 on the bus in a
brown paper bag it was like because you
want to feel that pain i come off the
bus okay
i'm sorry i come out of the uh the the
village um lantern walking down the
street this was june walking down the
street is tracy morgan with no shirt on
and a fifteen thousand dollar chain
so i switched so i see him and i don't
know crash he got a forty five thousand
dollars i know he upgraded yeah yeah
so he go so so i didn't you know i i
don't know tracy morgan of course i know
who he is but i never met him or
anything my ex-girlfriend at times like
tracy more like hey like because
everyone was kind of drunk and buzz was
like my boyfriend just did letterman he
goes oh and he goes my boyfriend right
here he goes oh [ __ ] and then he goes he
goes yo come over here playa so i go he
grabs me by like puts me like in a
headlock with almost like a sweaty
armpit and he goes um he goes oh your
girl is beautiful i was like thanks she
goes i like her toes they painted like
skittles
and i was like i was like yeah man it's
great he goes you just said david
letterman and i said yeah he goes how'd
it go and i was like it was good man i
had this you know i really felt like i
had a good set he goes i'm proud of you
man i always know from day one you was a
real [ __ ] i was like
i go i go i've never met you like i've
never met you at all i swear it's
percent true i go i go tracy i've never
met you guys nah nah nah i know you from
day one
day one i go i go yeah dude this is day
one and then he goes who's the other
people on the show who's the music guest
i was like i really don't remember he
goes was there anybody else on the show
i said john travolta and then i swear to
god he goes he put his hand on your
chest
i swear to christ and i was like he did
he was like yeah that boy cold oh wow
then he goes yo congratulations he goes
i'm gonna be seeing you
hand to god
six weeks later maybe less
i did that south beach comedy festival
comedy central south beach comedy
festival in miami in miami i you know
last minute edition so i might have been
a month later last minute addition to
the show
uh uh to uh i'm in the festival
tracy morgan's headlining the jackie
gleason theater down there he needs an
opener comedy central chooses me i open
i see him in the green room i go tracy
what's up man he goes who are you i was
like i met you a month ago outside the
village lantern whatever you know i'm
the guy who did letterman whatever he
goes day one he goes i don't know who
you are you want to water i was like uh
yeah sure i'll take a water then he
proceeds to give me he goes his age matt
frost matt frost is his age and goes
matt give this man some waters and then
i was like you know i i i get a take a
couple of bottles of water uh matt comes
over and gives me a couple bottles of
water he goes no no i give him a case i
want him to have a case of water so he
gives me a [ __ ] poland spring uh case
of water off a pallet i was like what is
this and i said to man i was like what
is it goes tracy morgan always needs a
pallet of water at every show he does i
was like okay wow
what a story it was great man amazing
but honestly dude it's [ __ ] like that
that's like i'm so happy that it worked
out that way yeah right yeah it'd be
weird if it was just you started opening
for tracy morgan and that's better he
didn't know what you were doing he
doesn't know he doesn't give a [ __ ] who
i am oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] keeps you funny
yeah being the butt of the joke keeps
you funny at the end of the day yes the
bus ride the 40. i love the idea that
your parents are fighting at letterman
you're in letterman's like why'd you get
into comedy you're like right there
right there
that's let's do yeah
oh yeah oh yeah well like i you know
just just this past weekend i did the
beacon theater and it was like a
beautiful moment for me sold out
whatever
not even close uh the by far the biggest
ovation was when i brought tt jerry and
homeless pimp on the stage i mean they
were like i was just like a [ __ ]
carcass just on the [ __ ] stage wait
we got to talk about the so sam's doing
the beacon coming up it's about to sell
out you're both new york guys new york
city what was it like i mean that's a
beautiful theater it's a special place
it's iconic were you nervous about
selling tickets did you know you had it
show us everything so so that's awesome
uh congrats to you sam congrats to you
my friend we're nice folks
hey these are better than they look too
dude honestly man i need a second one
yeah we might need more ice matt if
that's possible i spilled some of it on
my jeans thank god they were eight
dollars um
good if i don't mind i mean
whatever company sent us this [ __ ]
1888 hey man this is a good year
i'm watching that show 1883 by the way
it's on apple tv phenomenal show is that
the year bind was born
what uh what is it
so 1883 is a show about oh sam elliot's
in it um tim mcgraw yeah um it's a
really [ __ ] fantastic show westerns
are bad and there's like a scene like a
random scene in the show like so random
where they do a flashback to when the
main character tim mcgraw is fighting in
the civil war for the confederacy and
some he's like on the battlefield at
antietam which is like a very bloody
civil war battle and he's on the
battlefield it says flashback to
antietam whatever and he's like and a
union union
soldier captain or lieutenant comes over
and is like talking to him and he's like
it's going to be okay like i'm you know
i'm not going to kill you i'm not going
to hurt you and you're like oh whatever
and then the camera pans up it's [ __ ]
tom hanks
just a random bit part and then the same
then the very next episode they have a
sheriff that like comes in and kills
everybody and the share was billy bob
thornton and then
neither one of them ever come back in
the show again it's like it's like just
keeps you on your toes
uh john travolta touched his chest he's
like why is your heart beating so fast
soldier it's a [ __ ] great show man
1883 it's it's it's connected to that
show yellowstone
yellowstone another western so i got
mark on yellowstone so yellow so how far
deep into yellowstone are you i just
started the fourth season okay so the
fourth season so i think so do you know
like one you know when they flashlight
too much you know
but you know when they flash back to you
know kevin costner's john and when they
flash back to the 1800s sure that's the
show
that is this exact show every show has
gotten uh a alternate universe alternate
extended universe
you know i mean they got to be familiar
everything's got to be familiar now or
nobody watches it wait so let me tell
you about the beacon first of all the
one thing about us being new yorkers sam
is what and i don't know but what what
not that i i i don't want to i don't
want to say regret this i don't but what
i wish i would have done a little
different but i guess i can't okay it's
the guest list that i i had because it's
from new york so many people came there
and wanted to come to the green room and
this and that
it gave me so much it added a level of
pressure that i didn't need so if i
ever god will and get another chance to
do the beacon or something like that i
won't i won't invite all i'll just say i
can give you guys free tickets
absolutely no problem no green room
access no after party action i don't get
that it's a show you know like i was
that whole day i mean this is the only
job by the way they're not you're not
going to see like les mis and they're
like come in the green room no yes right
no so true well tim dillon did the
beacon and tim's a new york eye too and
tim was like you know he came to the
show and he said man you got so many
people here i said i know you know it's
a beacon whenever he goes dude i'm from
new york too i i told nobody to come
yeah he's like you gotta like i'm gonna
do a special and put it out on youtube
and the old me would have invited
everyone i want nobody's coming no you
don't i don't want anybody i don't want
my family there i don't want anybody
zero people i don't want my agent there
i want to do the show for my fans and
then you can watch the product exactly
you know show is number one i can't be
giving you energy and you time how was
your day get out oh you couldn't find
parking get out of here then i got i got
people texting me you know i go on stage
you know whatever the show starts at
eight o'clock i have people texting me
750. where are my tickets where exactly
what do i do are you going to do the
same set like i'm like what the so
that's a good question uh 759 yeah right
yeah so that's been my only advice for
you but honestly man i gotta be honest
the beacon theater it was one of those
experiences where
when i was about to be brought on james
madden uh sergio chacon featured a crush
and then james madden hosted and he's
just like such a great host
when he was about to bring me up it was
like one of those things where like i
just forgot all my material like it
happened like you know i'm sure we've
all been that situation where like i
just was like oh [ __ ] i don't even know
how i'm gonna open it i forgot but it
was like it's almost like a good thing
because like my brain almost like zapped
out and like started with a blank slate
and i just came out and was like so in
the moment yeah
by the time i got the light at 50
minutes i thought like i remember in my
head thinking i'm probably at about 20
now and then james was on the side with
the light for 50. i was like
oh that's good 50. and then i did like
it you know normally when i do a set you
know i'll get up to you know 55 minutes
whatever i'm like all right let me start
winding it down i must have did
80 minutes on that stage just because it
was just kept they're so loving you know
they're your people and they know it's a
it's a big they had fun man they had fun
and then and then i was like after i was
done i was like man that should have
been my special but instead i'm gonna do
it at new york comedy club
well you know yeah well you want the
club atmosphere too yeah but also i
think to shoot in a room that big is
going to do right got to cost 150 grand
well that's what they said well i was
going to do my special important same
agent and i'm sure he gave you the same
rundown that he gave you well i was
going to do my special in puerto rico
that would really stand out because i
was going to say oh you know i'm doing
on youtube in puerto rico i was going to
say to my i was going to say listen you
know these people you know like um uh uh
you know netflix doesn't want me amazon
doesn't want me showtime doesn't want me
i want to go back to where i'm loved
where the people love me puerto rico the
puerto rican government wants a hundred
grand for anything they don't love you
either i was like i guess you all don't
love me yeah i forgot
chris was going to open with i feel
pretty yeah
i was going to come out [ __ ] just
throwing paper towels into the crowd
you know what you got to say hey look
we'll have a [ __ ] fight first and then
it'll be free but you do a thing that i
do too and i like we got to cut it out
you we act as like underdogs and stuff
but it's like you're doing so well dude
you're crushing it like it's cool
he earned it though it's not like you
know what we're saying
some fat guy with a cigar like you're in
no one's joe hollywood here well no one
look show hollywood you gotta you gotta
get in with that guy but let me tell you
you did it the right way you did it
through your own baby oh doing the mics
together look at this now yeah yeah look
at us now drunk on uh
i knew you'd like the patrick ewing
thing yeah so patrick let me tell you my
patrick ewing stuff
so i got two of them he's got any you
could feed chris anything and you'll
have something i'm dying to hear your
harvey weinstein story
he touched
and he said your heart's beating so
quickly
so
patrick ewing my very first knicks game
how old were you
nine ten okay the thing sports for me
why why sports is so special for me is
because
it was an incentive when i was a child
to do good in school my father would say
if you do good in school if you listen
to your mother if you do this whatever
it is you will get tickets to in nick
games you will get tickets to a yankee
game so sports was incentivized for me
so that's why i fell in love with it it
was because that's how my father you
know got me to do what he needed me to
do so you know they were like you know
if you pass these get these good grades
and we're going to take you to the next
magic that was the first game we went to
shaquille o'neal's magic wow
yes yeah 1992 orlando magic so penny uh
that that finals team right was uh were
they they were the finals like 94.95 i
think so yeah but that's you they beat
jordan definitely penny definitely penny
and and uh and shaq
so
and scott skyles for sure so
he was a killer so i was a little kid
you know early 90s you know we're
sitting you know whatever upper deck
seats whatever
patrick ewing goes baseline and like
tomahawk dunks on shaquille o'neal and i
was like oh my god
and then he like you know shaquille had
like fallen under him so like patrick
had to like hang on the rim a little bit
so i go dad i like standable is like i
was like patrick ewing i was like dad
look at him he's swinging on the rim
like a big monkey
like that because to me it looked like a
monkey and my dad was just like pulling
me down pushing me down and everyone was
like looking over at me like whatever
and then my dad i
there's a thing i don't know if i try to
do like misremember this because i
thought it was like a a funny or i
thought it was like some type of defense
mechanism but i'm almost positive like i
would be willing to say i'm 95 sure this
he really said this is he looked around
because he got tense like oh really he
got yeah because i just yelled up and
said he's like a monkey and went well
the blackface didn't help yeah
yeah
and you know it's bad when you offend
yeah early 90s new york yeah and then my
dad i was gonna say it was 92-93 my dad
like said to like the general group
around me goes my son's [ __ ]
not special needs nothing because my
son's [ __ ] so he made it
by the way by the way his save is now
would make it 10 times worse right yeah
that's genius that's the time that's a
great boo it's like what kevin spacey
did he's he [ __ ] that kid he was like
well i'm autistic yeah he said i'm gay
or i'm getting to not help no that
didn't help you can't say it you can't
be accused of [ __ ] someone underage
and be like i'm gay that's not a sexual
orientation thing so kevin spacey let me
tell you my kevin spacey
[Laughter]
[Music]
so
so this this this was you know five six
years ago i had did i somehow got
involved i forgot how i initially got
involved but kevin spacey and cal ripken
jr the baltimore orioles you know iron
man hall of famer oh my god they had
some type of foundation down in
washington dc
and they i got hired to do uh to open
the show that they were doing like this
rally or or this fundraiser or whatever
i got hired to open the show wow and cal
ripped in how many years ago is this
this is maybe six seven pre-cancel no
yeah no there was no nothing about kevin
spacey it might have been months away
but kevin spacey was i mean he was being
he was a kevin spacey he was a god god a
legend so one of the best actors oh yeah
and funny guy so so great cal ripken
which by the way cal rivkin jr if you're
not a baseball fan google him his blue
eyes are like it's a little like poem
it's a little traumatizing piercing it's
insane pull it up
pull up cal ripken junior's eyes man he
must have really gotten laid well didn't
his mom get kidnapped yeah like yeah
something we got her back i think yeah
they got her back but cal ripken whoa
look at that that's real that's not
photo it's like uh
warlock or something and he's phenomenal
great player too oh yeah class act broke
lou gehrig's record like this really
first ballot hall of fame he got the
disease
i knew a guy when i started out he
passed away a really funny guy glenn
coyle had a joke where goes my
girlfriend got lou gehrig's disease so i
traded her
that's a great joke it's a great job
so she said michael keaton in him yeah
he's he's great very handsome so i i i'm
there
and first of all cal ripken i do my five
minutes which is like you know [ __ ]
five minutes opening up this thing cal
county girls he goes man i don't know
how you do what you do that i don't have
the balls to do that i was like you
literally are one of the greatest
baseball players of all time like what
are you talking about yeah nah stand
up's harder it's a different thing he
goes stand up hard i go cow it's not
okay i was like dude you're you're up
for like but to us it looks i mean
obviously baseball is harder but to us
to them that must be like yeah that's
not what they do think about the
repetition of just swinging right it's
like it's anti-social yeah right right
so it was cal ripken phil negro i don't
know if you don't feel negotiated hall
of fame knuckle ball pitcher i think he
just passed away and kevin spacey in the
green room wow
of course big three yeah and jasmine my
child my kids mom my girlfriend kid's
mom she's in there with me and it was
like
you know we're there so she sees all
this so kevin so phil necro and kevin
spacey are doing like
like horrifying not horrifying to a
comic but like if it ever got out like
audio leak like wild jokes like yeah
racist sexist like crazy [ __ ] you're
like whatever who gives a [ __ ] green
room yeah but then film uh
uh kevin spade this is pre stacy turns
to a camera if this ever gets out i'll
be finished
but then
but then kevin kevin um says something
to phil negro like you ever just kiss a
boy on the lips no way it's something
crazy and we were like
like come on it was a little bit like
and then we were like okay and then jazz
was like jasmine said to kevin's face
she goes what do you mean a boy he goes
no no like an 18 19 year old boy you
ever just kiss a boy in the lips
nothing's better and then it was so
weird and we were like okay like
whatever that's his testing ground
though 1819 that was his save yeah and
we were like yeah that's fine like
whatever it is it is you know cool
whatever and to be honest with you to be
fair to again i don't know him past this
he was mad cool that night yeah that was
[ __ ] awesome after i'm sure he's the
most charming guy on the planet yeah
after after i did my set he was right
there he was like phenomenal he was like
let's hang out let's do this let's do
that he was like we got to do all these
he was like we got to be i got to put
you in movies and this and that and then
he was like come find me in the after
party and then i i swear to god i lo i
saw him at the after party and i walked
up to him i was like hey kev i was like
hey kevin like i'm just about to go you
just told me to come find you and he was
like i'm a little busy right now and he
was talking to like some 21 year old
like
jacked gorgeous male waiter
and you ever heard him saying i got to
get you in movies yeah yeah
i've heard stories about the you know
touchy touchy touchy with stuff on set
and then if you were like you got to cut
it out he would cut it out but if you
didn't say something he would he would
keep that going well well the the the
reason why i bring it up is because
again no judge i don't know him other
than that but but we i remember i
remember in the car going back to our
hotel that night jasmine said to me she
goes kevin spacey's like a little like
it's a little much with him right and i
said yeah i said to be i said but i
think that's all how hollywood actors
are this is pre me too stuff so whatever
and then when all the [ __ ] came out
about him jasmine right away she was
like i told you that there was something
off about that guy i was on uh jim and
sam
right when that i think was the week it
came out yeah with john bernthal who was
in baby driver with him and john
bernthal was just openly like that guy's
a piece of [ __ ] what before it came out
oh it came out and john was like i've
never talked [ __ ] about an actor he's a
bad human being really and he was like
not nice he talked publicly it was on
air i'm sure there's record of it on air
somewhere i mean he would just say he
was just saying like yeah that's not a
good guy and it was like a news story
from that episode that yeah because it
was like john bernthal is a big actor
that's like a very nice guy i was on
sway in the morning which is like an all
you know black show black audience i was
like the guest host for sway in the
morning and the the the at while the
jesse smollet
news was breaking before anyone thought
he was lying like just a man who was
beaten and it was like that and i was on
with some guy like white jewish guy who
like owns a bunch of gyms and he goes um
sway was like you know everyone went in
a room how do you feel i was like oh
it's horrible it's you know this and
that but whatever and then because you
know the story did sound horrible and
then they got to me and i was like i
don't know if i believe it yeah and they
were like and they and they were like
what the [ __ ] they were like and nobody
like scolded me but like but you see
they're like that's that white [ __ ] with
white people like they don't believe
everything
and then it came out like two months
later that it probably was made up
because i was like it doesn't seem real
because my i i said there's proof of
this i said it on air i said because at
that time they were saying two
white uh they were saying the news
two white supremacists had said you're
that you're that you're that f word from
empire and i said there's no way white
people are watching empire no that's
what i said right on air you're not
you're not you're not a mega white
supremacist guy
and
watching [ __ ] oh there's no way
that's happening but that's bald ballsy
of you to do that in that black room
right yeah but i was trying to do i was
that was my bid i was like there's no
way they're doing that on empire like
that's a funny bit yeah i was just doing
it and they were like nah like no nobody
it wasn't like bad tough angle to take
when it's when it's the jury's still in
it or jerry's still out right i texted
sway two months later i was like apology
question mark
what'd he say he left it on red ah nah
nah sway's my boy i love sway ah sway's
one of those guys who i started he
taught me like when i was hosting like
shows in 2014 2015 he just gave me like
the best
advice the best tips yeah swake if you
ever get a chance to like work with sway
from sway in the morning sway calloway
he's like truly like one of the best
i've seen some of his interviews he's
great interviewed obama four times wow
you know like he's like a personal
friend like obama if you're listening
you got an open invite to we might be
drunk we'll get whatever booze you want
look i [ __ ] we our bartender didn't
make it tonight she's puerto rican we
know what chris does to puerto rican
women so we told her to stay home
honestly that's better for me and my
family like
yeah she's a good looking lady no but we
uh
yeah yeah but we but we you know if
you're into that sort of thing
hot latina women i'll make you i'll make
you a cocktail
one more actually yeah yeah yeah
we need more ice honestly dude this is
one somebody's got to drive my car to
the gramercy i'll drive i can drink and
drive like you wouldn't believe don't
say that i really can't i'm a great
drunk driver don't say it i grew up
drinking
this might be boring but i was watching
today the this this story of the
frontiers man and like i didn't know the
history of the american frontier like i
didn't realize like the historic
significance of new orleans like oh yeah
whoever controlled new orleans in like
the war of 1812 like there would be no
country if there wasn't no like the
french had to give up new orleans so so
i didn't know if you know this napoleon
you know who the france france owned
like the whole louisiana territory that
you know the louisiana purchase or
whatever so napoleon in like a drunken
stupor just gave
just [ __ ] sold louisiana to thomas
jefferson for like what would be the
equivalent of like a few hundred dollars
yeah just like when steinbrenner bought
the yankees yeah yeah it was like what
are you doing i know and i was like it's
[ __ ] interesting like i didn't did
not realize like i was like oh you know
[ __ ] whatever new orleans i know you
drink hurricanes you go on you know i
have mardi gras whatever but it's like
without that city dude there'd be there
would be no united states well you think
the united states well there would we
wouldn't we'd be half a country we would
stop at you know we'd stop in the
midwest maybe we'd be better let's go
back to the 13 colonies what do you guys
think we might be more we might be
happier i think we're already there
completely divided so
it's not uh it's not that different oh
nice dude i like that just a dirty
sweaty hand oh man i washed my hands
before this
huge man i'm sorry was that disgusting
that i just didn't know i love it
i haven't washed my hands since 1989.
i really
can't make me laugh when i'm making a
[ __ ] drink just telling the truth
dude i know 1989 goodyear that's enough
we got enough of that i'm like
legitimately [ __ ] green here i'm
freaking the toxic avenger over here you
don't like it oh cookies
what's this whose birthday is it
you guys want some cookies yes
thank you that's true that's great for
audio
happy birthday happy birthday chris this
is for the beacon congratulations oh
thank you thank you
yeah i saw the photo of you with your
family in the groomer i said that first
thought was that is really sweet second
thought is that's got to be hell yeah i
know i was like well
that's the thing dude i have the same
thing with my family where like i'm so
grateful they come to shows it means the
world to me that my parents but like
holy [ __ ] like they've come when i did
found they come when i do colbert they
come and it's like it's so meaningful
but the same time you're like man it's
very stressful yeah
i'm i've told my family already like i
want to do i'm going to put a special on
youtube kind of you know like you guys
did and i'm just going to do it at new
york comedy club because i'm like i just
want to get it out i want to get the
material out but i told my family like
you can't come yeah i don't want you to
come
i don't mean to be disrespectful like i
it just adds a level of pressure that i
that is not necessary agreed so i'm not
i'm not gonna do it thank you sam i
think that's the move so i'm not going
to do it this is a [ __ ] great cookie
a little stale but great
i'm okay with the stale cookie i don't
mind yeah especially with the booze
cooking i like these right here so
whatever the hell these are called i'm a
big fan i don't know they're thin so you
don't feel like they're as bad for you
but they're delightful i like a crunchy
cookie cut a cookie you're right
hey i'll tell you here split it with me
split it with me all right all right you
want half of this man i hate those
i hate it too it's too gay it's like the
pride flavor what'd you eat today mark
anything good no i eat a lot no i tried
i ate oatmeal and uh
that was it and i came here mark doesn't
eat much what are you eating oh it's a
sandwich we had a business an egg
sandwich and then i had a uh a turkey
sandwich i'm a boring eater
how do you guys stay so thin do you just
eat right you didn't do you're not no no
i'm not i'm 240. what really yeah well
you hide it well you know that's what
i'm saying so it's all about the angles
[Laughter]
oh i dropped martina i just i'm i uh
what no i normally eat more exciting
than that on the road i i try to eat go
to good restaurants because i want to i
want to at least like feel the city
you won't eat like dominoes or anything
no well i'll never eat dominoes because
we live in new york [ __ ] city where i
can eat great pizza on any corn why
would any dominoes when we can get
better slice than any corner man oh
shoot but i'm saying if you're in that
[ __ ] city no i don't i won't eat
pizza on the road unless they've got a
good road pizza spot like if i'm in new
haven connecticut i'll eat people you
don't ever like hate yourself after a
scent and just get pizza hut or
something
i've done it but it's like i usually
will like panda express bring it on yeah
yeah i i stopped the asian hate exactly
here here is that real let's talk about
it asia
imagine i go into it let's talk about
the rock he's a transphobe
i yeah um yeah i guess i don't really i
don't know look at this guys i've always
been thin since i've known i've known
you my whole i've known you since 2000
i've known both you guys since like 12
years now you guys we're like
significant parts of each other's lives
yeah it's wild i've known you for so
long to know somebody for 12 13 years
you know like and to like someone for
that how insane i know how like how
insane that is you may not see each
other all the time but it's like the
fact that like we very well could be in
each other's lives for like 30 years
that's why i invited everybody to the
wedding because i'm like i've seen all
these [ __ ] grow kids no kids
married who's somebody who's somebody if
you just [ __ ] say it we're drunk
who's somebody that just missed the cut
come on mark all right cosby
he could take my place
no because i put them at my table i'll
just wash my drinks that's the first
time i'll ever be in new orleans is for
your wedding what you never been there
man dude get there early do the tours
me and my girl plan on getting their
three four days what's your date again
mark
all right do we believe that i heard
that i heard that's a good time to do it
because it it's not so oppressively hot
it's the best month of november we've
tried these dollars by the way oh yeah
what do they have blue cheese in them or
something yeah dudes yeah that's great
do they really
we might be drunk and sponsored by
better help online therapy relationships
take work a lot of us will drop anything
to go help someone we care about we'll
go out of our way to treat other people
well but how often do we give ourselves
the same treatment for me
working out or buying some new sneakers
is an investment in myself this month
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to take care of your most
important relationship the one you have
with yourself we're in therapy we go to
the same guy it's necessary clean out
the garbage your head has all these
horrible thoughts
splicing your childhood traumatic
experiences you're a wreck you're a mess
you need therapy get out the garbage
whether it's hitting the gym making time
for a haircut or even trying therapy
you're your greatest asset so invest
time and effort into yourself like you
do for other people tell them how better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
maybe you got a weird boil on your face
or something you're weird you know you
don't want to see that you're all said
yep it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours give
it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy we might be drunk is sponsored
by better help and listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
drunk that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com
slash drunk you got to do this it's it's
therapy very important take care of
yourself it's going to change your life
here here
we might be drunk is thrilled to welcome
our new sponsor fanimel
i love live events i hate buying tickets
the hidden fees suck and coordinating
with your friends is the nightmare
they're garbage i always end up fronting
a bunch of money and chasing down my
friends to get reimbursed not me
personally because i'm very generous but
if they flake i'm stuck with the whole
bill and then i discovered fandible
fanable has tickets to everything
there's no fees the price you see is the
price you pay that's i mean that's
pretty big yeah not only those prices
transparent but they're almost always
lower than anywhere else i look and for
any hot ticket like coachella a laker
game or dave chappelle fanimal is always
the cheapest option nobody gives nobody
goes to live events anymore so why buy
tickets alone fanimal although if you do
come to a show alone there's nothing
wrong with that honestly i love that
like someone tweeted me about that the
other day they're like i wanna is it
weird my friend's bails are weird if i
come alone i said no dude enjoy yourself
yeah and you know what the guy made new
friends at the show they tweeted me
afterwards i sat with these guys and
they were tweeting me too so you end up
having a great time no matter what um
fanimal's patent group purchase makes it
easy first you set a minimum size for
your group and you choose the number of
tickets you want to pay for yourself
then you invite friends when the minimum
size is met everyone gets charged and
receives their ticket if the minimum
size isn't reached in time nobody gets
charged you don't commit until your
friends you march tell them how mark i
called you march
march march normand tell them how to do
it oh yeah and family has amazing
customer service don't take my word for
it check out their hundreds of five-star
reviews the next time you need tickets
go to fanimal.com and sign up with
code drunk
for twenty percent of credit
twenty dollars of credit towards your
first purchase we drink on this show
check out fanimel and experience more
support the show and get twenty dollars
off your first purchase with the code
drunk at
fanimal.com f-a-n-i-m-a-l
dot-com get on it hey folks we might be
drunk is brought to you by manscaped oh
yeah set your first new year's
resolution with good intentions and join
the four million men worldwide who trust
manscape with our exclusive offer go to
manscape.com and use promo code drunk
for 20 off plus free shipping holy hell
i love manscape i use the ball wash i
shave with the the lawn mower it's good
stuff it gets it in tight i keep it in
my travel bag i just whatever i need it
it's all there you got the crop
preserver crop reviver
uh you got the lawnmower 4.0 it's got a
light on it for christ 6. i love this
thing they love it they even uh they
they have a travel bag i still use boxer
briefs they're great
and uh the ultra premium body wash is
great for manscaped love manskip i just
use their shampoo and conditioner if i'm
being honest yeah yeah oh yeah i use it
today that's where this [ __ ] load of
bird's nest came from
but yeah get it get on it folks
yeah i got some of that shampoo in my in
my uh shower too hey whether your
resolution is to work out more or to
travel to new places be sure to travel
to manscape.com
for our exclusive offer of 20 off plus
free shipping with the code drunk that's
20 off and free shipping with the code
drunk at manscape.com
one last time one last time sorry i've
been drinking 20 off with free shipping
at manscape.com use the code drunk it's
the new year no pubes in 2022
with manscaped support the show and get
20 off from free shipping with the code
drunk at manscape.com hell yeah get on
it man and look better and smell better
i only [ __ ] with blue cheeve or jalapeno
olives dude i like it what about a
regular olive oil i'll do an olive all
right i don't know why i said it so
definitely my cousin put olives on her
fingers on her fingertips and dipped
them all in mayonnaise and she used to
eat them and one time she's puked so
hard they started coming out of her nose
cousin honey boo boo
[Laughter]
yeah dude i'm excited to go i'm excited
to go to um
to new orleans because uh you know love
and history and i love um i've just
never really been to like the deep deep
south like i've been in nashville and
florida but like new orleans is like the
sun
yeah you got that right yeah but there's
no road in new orleans right like where
can we play in louisiana they have they
have harrah's i guess there's hairs but
there's a couple little theaters there's
the casino yeah you've done it no i
haven't done it but no one does it big
comics go there i guess it's a big app
what is it 2000 seater or something no
not even it's like a little improv in
the hair really yeah but no one does it
it's like i saw a dat fan there once in
nineteen i opened for that fan at too
late i mean i was at two lanes oh there
you go yeah i forgot you went to a lot
of people went to tulane right
oh jeff sonic because when i first
started it was i
it's interesting when i first started i
had this complex or this insecurity
because
you guys are such like comedy historians
you know everybody's albums and all that
stuff and i remember feeling like
insecure where i was like i don't know
much about the history of comedy i've
never been to new orleans all you guys
were like doing like the so those are
the two those are so now because
everybody was from new orleans you went
to tulane you sean patton uh three
people no no no um
chesley theo all those dazzle neck went
to jail everybody was from new orleans
and i was like i'm a piece of [ __ ]
that's i thought you needed a passport
to go over the brooklyn bridge how do
you think i felt i come to new york all
you [ __ ] are new yorkers i was
on a fish out of water and i like dude i
remember when you were
inside remember when mark was a janitor
you used to do it professor tom's on
second half i did that and then we used
to and then we did you the show used to
run with harrison i did that show what
was that show um what was the name of
that event sage sage
yeah and harrison was like for all these
shows
sage sage was a great [ __ ] and he had
another one on second avenue what was
that party too
that's that's what i should do the open
mic in there and then stay for your
guy's show with harrison
harrison greenbaum it was hard to find
that was a great [ __ ] [ __ ] hell yeah
that that's not even a venue anymore
right barney too it's like oh no
completely um i actually haven't walked
by it in [ __ ] ever that was a good
bar too
dude i had a lot of fun at bar 82. i
used to be a physical therapist so i
would do physical therapy remember
we did some road gigs together back in
the day yeah three of us did one
remember what we did mohigan sun that
one time we did all three of us yeah oh
with amy yeah
we were there with amy it was it was way
longer like a triple headliner
oh scott robert he was doing the story
on him and we drove home that night
don't you remember scott ryan i remember
without rob yeah but i don't remember
there was us three and scott rob in the
car i remember that yeah and i think you
were headlining because they were uh
esquire magazine we were co-headlining
and you were opening it
was yeah
yeah not ringing about well i got to the
beacon first [ __ ]
but you guys will get to radio city
first
dude how about this uh hassan minaj
texted me the other day shout out to
samanage uh he's another guy started
comedy with hassan minaj and dude the
very first television show i ever got to
be a part of was philosophy and uh it
was on mtv hassan was the host and
[ __ ] kevin barnett was was my was the
panelists me and kevin were the
panelists r.i.p
i missed kevin so much
he texts me last night he goes hey man
are you around to do a set february 25th
to 27th i'm doing some shows in new york
i said uh i can't do 25 or 26 i'm on the
road but 27 just let me know the venue
and he writes back radio city i was like
you're doing a weekend at radio city
goes yeah i got five shows there i was
like dude you're throwing that around
like a [ __ ] like like it's an improv
yeah he's just doing five at radio city
banging him out what is that twenty
thousand no five thousand no six
thousand seats in radio city so thirty
bucks there once
did you bomb in radio station for the uh
mtv music awards wait so what are you
doing how many shows are you
doing what i'm saying
he's huge i thought he'd do more than
that no no
i think what i'm saying through the
garden if you do if you're doing five
in a six thousand seater that's thirty
thousand thirty thousand oh that's
bigger than the garden which is 20 000.
he's gonna he's huge like i'm not
shocked at all that he's doing that
crazy
he's that's my goal
i would
uh that is my goal
if i could just get to do one i didn't
have to sell it out one show at madison
square garden where i'm the headliner
that would be my goal you'll get there
well yeah you'll get there i mean the
garden now feels like uh like a funny
bone in albany i mean it's like
sebastian's doing 13 of them louie did
10 bird did a couple it's just schumer
did one or two or three or four did you
open further yeah i had to follow
madonna
fun fact
she looked great by the way yeah did you
have the fake ass yet yes she did best
she's a fake ass oh yeah pull up
madonna's ass i mean it's wild
just pull it right you know it's your
whole thing really don't have something
to google it this guy's acting on camera
she's googling 68 years old and she's
got the ass of uh
chloe kardashian she's got the ass of my
kids my kids uh grandmother look at that
thing nice puerto rican s i'm good i
don't like those
that's a little ridiculous hey that was
anti-semitic
yeah can't adapt to this guy
oh look at that wow
no she didn't have that ass when i saw
her i got it
i think that um you know because what i
heard about madison square garden is you
don't really have to sell all those
tickets because scalpers buy them
immediately um
right away scalpers buy the table look
it dude that's right
yeah yeah
should us should the three of us do the
garden like we did which and get scott
robeck
shout out to scott rob man great writer
is he still with us yeah yeah he looked
like a guy who was who could die he lost
a lot of weight did cover kill him no
i'm kidding oh he lost a lot of weight
he looks great oh he just got robbed
shout out scott rob that's great did
that piece ever come out on you uh i
don't think so he was thinking i tried
to kill him on the lips
he touched his heart rate
he no he uh
he wrote a great book he's written a few
great books i remember scott rob on on
that drive home was just a really cool
nice guy sweet kid yeah wait a good egg
yeah i like scott rob he used to buy me
diner meals and he was like i don't know
how you run around like this because he
was a big guy and i'd be like ah yeah he
would get cabs everywhere because he'd
want to run so it was great for me
that's the thing too is like you know
like just now just recently i think it's
the same for all three of us is we just
the tickets are starting to come and the
podcasting and all that found but it's
like you know like people don't know
like you know from 2009 to like
literally a year ago it was slaving like
hell like like i mean doing sh i
remember dude i used to go and hope i
went up i was a physical therapist and i
drove all the way to delaware just to do
five minutes in front of mike vecchio he
graciously gave me 20 bucks and then i
drove all the way home and went right to
my day job like yeah that's like
sometimes i'll get messages from up and
coming comics or whatever and be like
hey like i have a day job and like it's
just so hard how did you do it and i'm
like man if you're already messaging me
that like you're never gonna make it
like yeah i just i just was like there's
no excuses i just want to make it so bad
that i'm like i'll just
i drove all the way up to the boston
comedy festival you're always a hustler
man thursday night i'll never forget
thursday night 2012 drove all the way up
to the boston comedy festival uh the
first round to try to do five minutes
just to get to the second round which
would be the next week that's you know
to win a [ __ ] prize whatever just do
anything i got immediately eliminated
from the first round like immediately
just do you remember who beat you i draw
adam newman
that's hilarious i just gave him
chiropractic advice and uh adam newman
yeah where's adam newman
does he live in new york he's in l.a
he's adam newman he's a nice guy he was
another guy he was part of ours
caroline's he was always a character
now yeah no he tweeted something how he
needed a chiropractor in l.a and i was
like good man yeah what are you going to
physical therapy for oh my god two
herniated discs in my neck in your neck
yeah [ __ ] how did that happen eating
[ __ ] uh yeah i just ate a lot of [ __ ]
and it just it took a toll i mean i was
you're the best ever and i was like look
if this is the toll it takes and i'm
down so yeah that's like one i swear to
god one guy he came in when i was i was
a physical therapist he came in and he
had a herniated disc out i think it was
c5 or c6 that's what i got that's mine
so see so this is funny so c5 c6 he
comes in and he's like he's like um you
know there's this big herniated disc
whatever in my boss this wasn't me my
boss
who goes um he's like you know doing
that he's like how do you think this
happening goes oh
he goes um he goes uh i think it was you
know lifting up my kid or maybe it was
swinging a baseball bat and then my boss
says to me goes he goes you sure it
wasn't uh going down on a woman really
the guy and the guy goes uh the guy goes
yeah i think it was going down on a
woman
you know like whatever goal was going
down the woman he goes well
historically statistically if you if
you're herniated c5 or c6 it's because
you're sucking [ __ ] like just joking
around like just full like just a joke
whatever ha and the guy goes yeah i am
gay
like that like and he was like okay no
problem like you know like whatever and
i was like and like the guy like who
said yeah i am gay i was like
it was a moment where like it was
laughed off but like i had the angle and
like he truly like came out of the
closet to us it was like begging for
help i was like that guy was fully gay
yeah and just was like yeah and like i
was like i was like yikes we were just i
mean hey whatever you want to do but
yeah yeah yeah wow lay off your
alternative lifestyle for a few weeks
because we're trying to help you here
dude so and that was kevin spacey
one crazy physical thera well two crazy
physical therapy stories i have one
um
this was 2000
maybe yeah guy comes in
back pain okay just back pain just
generalized back pain so you know you
learn all the tests to reproduce you
know being a physical therapist is a lot
of times people haven't come in with
mris or x-rays yet so you have to try to
reproduce their pain and then it kind of
you work backwards to figure out how did
this injury happen and then that can
dictate how i treat you right so this
guy came in with this generalized back
pain i'm doing all the tests that i've
learned
and because there's even tests to know
if somebody's faking it for like a
workman's comp there's even tests that
we learn how to do that to be like ah ha
like you're lying and then you know we
can you know we won't let you you know
get away with that yeah and and um and
all these tests are are like not working
like everything i'm like it's not
workman's comp it's not this not that
what the hell is going on with this guy
so i had i was a you know i was a
licensed physical therapist but i was
new so i call in my boss who's you know
30-year professional and i say hey like
jim i i don't know like what's going on
with this guy like it's embarrassing but
like can you come in and help he was
like absolutely like you know whatever
your new student like your new therapist
like you know i'll come in so going he's
doing he did every test i did he's like
i can't figure it out so he says to me
goes what's going on here sir he's like
you know you just be honest with us
what's going on he goes i don't know man
i hurt my back and he goes um okay he's
like but is there something else like
that's going on like
any information would help us we want to
help you get out of pain because he was
in excruciating pain you believe him or
you wanted some pills uh well i at fir
that's where i was going i was like
maybe this guy wants pills
so
in the physical therapy office that i
was working at that time there was also
a medical an orthopedist that had an mri
machine an x-ray machine so you know
everybody was pretty close so he says
you know what let's go get you an mri
this way i can at least see the tissue
and whatever so you know we don't go
into the mri that's you know another
professional's job the mri or x-ray tech
comes out and gets the doctor the
orthopedist immediately and comes over
and he's like
we're like something's like maybe it's a
tumor i don't know like something was
serious
so then my boss and this orthopedist are
friendly so they go over and they start
laughing looking at the picture they're
laughing and i was like the [ __ ] so i
think the guy my boss jimmy goes chris
come here come here this is like my
second week on the job
he goes look at this look at this it's a
gerbil no i didn't know what it was no
no wasn't that it was a matchbox car wow
he was taking his kids matchbox this is
a true story he was taking his kids
matchbox cars and shoving them up
shoving them up his ass with condoms
that would like he was trying to like um
like massage his prostate like it was
the only way he could come and he had
gotten one of the matchbox cars lodged
in his back and it was pushing on his uh
lower like lumbar spine
so he go we go in
we go in and he goes um we go into the
guy and and we and you know my boss says
listen we got the mri results and uh you
know you have a matchbox car or what
looks like a matchbox car some type of
item far enough we don't know the brand
per se but you're [ __ ] the guy and
the guy goes and the card swear to god
in new york
the guy goes the guy looks and he goes
now how'd that get there i'll never
forget he goes now how'd that get there
that's great and i was like and i was
like okay and then and then the guy says
listen it's no problem like my boss is
you know you got to be professional he's
no problem at all
and goes um but you know you have to get
that surgically
removed on top of it i asked her to
listen no but on top of that on top of
that
my boss then you know says you know
listen can you just disrobe so maybe i
can get it out you know what but when he
disrobes he sees he has a full like like
rat like it almost his dick and balls
look like purple
so we're like what's happening now so so
you know because now like multiple cars
traffic yeah yeah so he goes so he goes
um
he goes uh is that bad and my boss says
that looks like a sexually transmitted
disease and he goes and he goes oh but
i'm only with i've only ever been with
my wife he's like well you know you
might want to talk to your wife and the
guy goes yeah
i got to talk to my wife and then like
we're doing the exam and then like five
minutes goes by he goes i've had been
having sex with prostitutes you think
that could be it and then my boss is
like yeah i'd say that's it yeah he goes
how can we keep this a secret and then
my boss says
you know there's you know it's it's it's
client you know uh client privilege like
i'm not gonna we won't say anything he
goes yeah but i need medicine i need
medicine to get rid of this disease that
i have i think it wound up turning out
he had like gonorrhea or and chlamydia
like he was [ __ ] yeah so he says he
was at that time one of and this is way
before the presidency one of donald
trump's lawyers whoa so he says to me
because i was two three weeks onto the
job he says hey you're a young guy i was
single at the time you're representing
stormy daniels yeah
yeah he goes would you mind
kind of putting this
std medication in your name and then
i'll come pick it up from your house
i'll pay a thousand dollars a week for
it hey
and so i so i was like that now it was
just me because my boss had left to go
you know get a hot pack or whatever so
he he kind of what and i didn't know
what to do i was 24 at the time a
thousand dollars a week sounds pretty
good pretty good but i didn't know what
to do so in that moment i kind of made a
decision i said i said hold on like let
me think about it and i went out and
it's the only time in my life i ratted i
ratted and i told i tol i know my
father's like you [ __ ] rat yeah i
told my boss i said this is what
happened he goes he goes into him he
goes get the [ __ ] out of my office like
right like they were friends these
people he was get the [ __ ] out of my
office he goes you're gonna you're gonna
do this to a young because this guy this
kid just got his license you're gonna
you're gonna ruin his entire life
because you want to [ __ ] prostitutes he
goes get the [ __ ] out of my office i
never want to see you again get the [ __ ]
out and the guy wouldn't leave and then
my my my boss goes you wanna call your
wife right now and tell her what's going
on i have her number two then the guy
was like you know pull up his pants
whatever and he goes he goes you know
you could have like just ruined your
whole career if you would have done that
he goes you know that's malpractice
that's you know code of ethics you could
have done everything you know ruined
your whole life and i said i know like
thank god i was like you know and he was
like you know you want to you want to do
this for 20 years like you would ruin
your whole life i was like absolutely
about
10 days later mtv called me we're like
hey we'll offer you we will offer you an
overall deal if you quit physical
therapy tomorrow i went and i said i
[ __ ] quit i was like and you called
the guy's wife yeah i was like i'm not
doing it yeah and i [ __ ] the guy's
wife
i was like i was like you want to get
gonorrhea i'll give you guys
wow yeah so yeah then and then and then
a woman came in
she had lower back pain
i'm sorry she had uh tennis elbow
lateral epicondylitis which they called
tennis elbow right
so she's got tennis elbow
treating her for two hot like 40 year
old divorcee hot so she goes um
she goes uh she you know coming in for
the tennis elbow treating her all is
good and then finally she comes she
comes in one day and she goes she goes
the pain is like radiating to my lower
back i was like that's not possible from
tennis elbow but you know she goes but
it's in my lower back i was like well
you got to go get like a script you got
to get a prescription from an
orthopedist and and they have to refer
you and then we can treat your lower
back pain she's like can you just be
like
can you just like massage my lower back
please like it's just like temporary i
was like okay so start massaging her
lower back
and she goes can you do a little lower
i'm already on like the top of her like
they're called like your sits bones i'm
more like which is like those like
dimples that you see over like a
person's like i love that dimples back
dimples so i'm right there i'm massaging
my thumbs whatever she goes go a little
lower i was like i was like man that's
like your butt she's like that's where
the pain is
okay so then she goes i'm massaging it a
little bit there she goes lower
i was like i was like come on like i was
like are you serious she goes you're 24
25 years old she's like you don't want
to massage a hot 40 year old's lower
back wow and i was like i do she was
like well then do it and then i would
start like going lower i was like you
sure this is okay she's like i want you
to do this and i was like oh my god she
goes does that door lock i was like i
think it does jesus i swear to god
i had a [ __ ] boner through my khakis
like you can't imagine and she goes um
she goes just go lower so i kept going
lower and low and lower and then i got
to like the top of her [ __ ] which was
like soaked and she's going to stick
your fingers in it and i was like oh my
god and then i swear to god is this a
penthouse forum i don't believe this i
finger i like put like my finger like i
was like this is crazy so i put my
fingers in her and she goes and she like
grabbed my [ __ ] which like i said was
rock hard i i married docker's khakis on
and they were like ripping at the seams
stain proof thank goodness yes and she
goes just unzip it so i unzipped it and
my [ __ ] boner just like popped out
like
like that and she sucked it four times i
blew a little more times yeah like oh
four four strokes dude you know how hot
that is
i just blew a load in her mouth wow she
was like oh you're such a baby i was
like don't say that and then she and
then but i had
but i was like that was one of the
craziest [ __ ] stories
a woman
hot older woman and i for the life of me
and this is a good thing i cannot
remember her i remember her first name
not her last name wow ladies see how
easy it is it must be nice to be a gal
that's female privilege well then i told
my boss about that again 30 years of
experience he goes ah your first one i
said
i said my first one he goes that that
happens every six months in in an office
like this i was like really he goes yeah
he goes he goes they you know a lot of
times like these women like you know
you're helping them you're giving them
something their husband or or if they're
single that they don't get and you're
good at you know
you know you're helping them ease their
pain i was like i was like but isn't
that wrong he was like yeah it is but he
was like [ __ ] it there's healthcare oh i
was like okay yeah yeah then sticking a
[ __ ] matchbox car up your ass wrong
shoulder we're here to help people with
damage human beings god damn it that's
like gay's anatomy oh yeah dude gay gays
anatomy gays anatomy is what i should
name my special that's that's a that's a
gay porn right there
man what a story that's hot turned on it
was hot [ __ ] man man a lab you put a lab
coat on a woman will do anything for
sucks that's the name of your next
special dude yeah that's like one time i
was like maybe 22 23 walking down
like sixth avenue-ish like you know like
that part of the west village kind of by
the comedy cellar where it's like i
don't know where they even what like all
the streets [ __ ] intersect and i'm
like i don't even know it was like
around west fourth park it's not a grid
anymore yeah i don't know what the hell
was going on madness it was like maybe
four cars so i'm walking out
i'm walking down the street and my boy
was with me i'm walking down the street
and it's like you know 10 o'clock at
night summer night
and uh you know way before comedy i was
in the city hanging out and um a woman
comes out like you know what didn't look
homeless they don't look crazy nothing
she comes out of an apartment she goes i
just need to suck somebody's dick i have
to suck i swear to god i want to do this
she was like i feel like an mtv show i
swear to god she goes well that's what i
thought i like it or not she goes i just
have to suck somebody's dick i thought i
was on punk'd that punk was popular at
that time with ashton kutcher she goes i
just need to suck somebody sick i was
like
i was just i was just there me and my
brother were just there and she goes you
boys want to get your dick sucked and
and i was like we both were like what
she goes and takes a mask off it's john
travolta yeah yeah i was like yes
and then she literally got on her knees
at 10 30 at night on whatever street
that was and sucked both of our dicks
for
neither one of us came but it was like
two minutes and then she walked away
there's eight guys booking a flight to
new york right now i know it was you're
gonna save this economy yeah
it's true
what yeah that those are like that those
are like moments of my life from like
was that real did that really just
[ __ ] happen my virginity was like
that a lady was on the on the balcony
flashing on bourbon street we looked at
her we said hi she said come up and that
was how i lost that's [ __ ] nuts every
now and then
but see for a guy this is like a godsend
for a woman this is a
a you know victim moment it's
fascinating how different it is well now
i've gone to an age i'm 37 now and maybe
i've had enough sex or enough sexual
experience in my life for now it's like
i know this sounds like
gay and weird but like i really like if
i was single like i really would like
rather be with a woman because of her
personality than her looks i feel like
i'm getting old too i'm 38 and i feel
the comments are exploding right now
like i get the fake tits i get the fake
answer i know what a [ __ ] feels like
i know what it's like to have sex with a
hot woman from every i get it it's like
can i have a conversation with you like
do you want to talk about history
i like history and [ __ ] like do you want
to do that it's fascinating i mean you
have to be somewhat attractive we're
normal
like men and women trade places with age
like when we're in our you know
eighteens and twenties it's like oh [ __ ]
anything i'll [ __ ] blow up to all a
[ __ ] dumpster whatever it is and then
women are all like i need a personality
and then women start getting horny at 30
whatever and men get a little more like
i need a person i need to talk to
somebody yeah they flip yeah
i'm trying to say as we get older we
become better
yes yeah they turn into men they get
horny they do they just want to get
casual sex they're divorced they're
[ __ ] ready to go you know i'm with
you chris i mean the older i get it's
like yes
that [ __ ] the peace and the just
chilling well you have a good
relationship with your girl because it's
more of the personnel i mean she's
beautiful but it's more of the
personality-based stuff it's like so
much in common it's like it's like i get
like the thing is it's like i get it i i
know what it's like to have sex with
beautiful i get it it's like if there's
no connection it's like ah and it also
lasts 12 seconds yeah i get it dude i'd
rather jerk off i'd rather [ __ ] a guy
that i'm really into am i saying
dude what are you doing later maybe you
want to hang out
i'm doing ari's show oh i'm going to
[ __ ] bomb do you have any stories
prepared i'm doing i'm doing a very
short story that i've been doing in my
act
see here's this is there is there is
there a uh hey is that fair is he
allowed to do that i think i the 30
years
the story all right is that fair you
mean for being prepared is that fair
i'll allow it
how the [ __ ] is going to be [ __ ] talking
me because i [ __ ] worked on my story
i'm not sure i'm jealous i'm like i'm my
[ __ ]
we're we're worried about ours we're
going to bomb up there it's like why am
i we got to get norman bomb with a
prepared bit that's even more
embarrassing at least you guys aren't
you got to get norman and berkowitz but
let me just say you went back uh
your adderall hasn't kicked in because
we're all over the road i know sorry
about that we gotta talk about the fact
that we talk about the early stages how
horrible that was how hard it was
driving to delaware for five five bucks
five minutes whatever it is
i don't know if i could do it again
could you do it again the fact that we
were in our 20s you're drunk the whole
time you're you're ambitious you're
looking for adventure it made it okay
but
knowing how hard it was i don't know if
i wouldn't know now i don't know if it's
worse or better i mean it's better
because of social media
because right you can kind of blow up if
you have a decent act on social media
but there's no shortcuts in stand up
but dude i'll say this we might have
been drawing earlier if we started now
only because of social media like i
agree with you but our act might be
stunted because you're just so focused
on so you i'm happy it took 12 years for
us to start to sell tickets because now
i know at the very least i'll give them
a good show you know yeah no i think
you're probably right i just think uh
i think it works both ways where you
know well how many people do you see
putting out albums two years in and
you're like oh what are you doing now
you're just showing people how not good
you are you're not putting that out
there i think i think what happened what
happens with with must have happened
with all of us to you know to get
through whatever 10 12 years of this is
i never stopped for a sec i never
thought about how hard it was going to
be to make it i never thought about that
i just said i'm gonna and i never tried
to do any tricks i never tried to do
like oh maybe i'll get big because i'll
you know i know the algorithm i never
thought about that i said i want to get
if i'm going to get big and popular i
wanted to be on the backbone of my jokes
i wanted to be on my bits yeah that's
what i want i don't want it to be on
because i went viral because i you know
somebody hit me in the face with a
watermelon right i don't want that right
you know how we close our shows
dude [ __ ] nail me with a watermelon
dude i hear you well you did it the
right way i mean everyone respects you
because of that but i mean it is
definitely uh
it's a slower rise but i would hope we
we stay a little longer because of this
that it took
i think you know there's some people
that i don't know what just fell on
there
an egg oh is my girl pregnant again
that's a strong christmas sperm
i shot a load on it nine months but i
think when like you know what i remember
the
degree
it must have been like eight years ago
louis said something maybe was less than
eight maybe it was like five or six but
like louie said you don't want to do
this you want to do this
you want
yeah man i mean shout out i also think i
didn't put i didn't put like a album out
i mean none of us put our [ __ ] out for a
while i still don't have an album out
i'm putting it out
well i got a special but no album i'm
putting my first album out how many
central next year
album too why not
i don't know it's just part man they
[ __ ] you yeah they [ __ ] i did my half
hour special i did my hour special and
that's all i have and they never gave
you any audio on that no no i'm gonna do
it for the first time next month and put
it out in a month but but but but we
should all re-record our [ __ ] because
spotify is just raping us yeah spotify
pulled two of my albums they pull you
out yeah yeah spotify just it's like
they're allowed
young [ __ ] is a distraction from the
fact that they don't pay their artists
they don't they don't pay comics they
pay they know why i found out why
because
when you're a musician you got to pay
the the writer the performer and whoever
that's a comic is all those things so
they'd have to pay us all those
those uh and they've maybe there's like
a new deal to be had where it's like i
don't know because we should be getting
paid for that it's like it's like some
what we write all our own material like
you know somebody who writes a script
they get paid on that like i'm writing a
script but it's on i'm performing that's
why we're all doing nine podcasts
exactly
cookies you're getting drunk at noon
dude i'm [ __ ] feeling great right
isn't that dude i'll tell you that
that's a pretty good martial honestly
dude that i feel like i'm a decent
bartender here no you are because and
i'm sorry i judged you immediately
because i was like there's no way that's
going to taste good and now it's like
dude
is that a gin or vodka i can't believe
it okay you asked for vodka i did yeah
hey man i went on that bottle we would
never disrespect the guests dude yeah
we're happy you're here happy to have
respect no good to have you wait hold on
i want oh i did a gotham i did i had
like one conan under my belt and maybe
like a half hour or something comedy
central and gotham called and they said
well you do a panel and talk to young up
and coming comics i was like look i'm
nobody but i'll do it
every guy there was like i work a day
job i have two dogs there's no way i can
do open mics what do i do or how do i
get an agent out of the gate and you're
like the dogs are worse than the job
because the dogs are like are you gonna
get rid of the dogs right and i was like
you're all you're screwed you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] and i was like do you want
to do comedy yeah i think i like comedy
oh you're out you're already out if
you're putting this [ __ ] in front of
comedy then it's not gonna work you
gotta love it yeah you gotta love it you
gotta wanna do it well that's the thing
is like it's it it's not just comedy
it's like anything you wanna do in life
like any audience member that's
listening whatever your goal is in life
just understand the money comes second
you have to put the passion first and
the money will always come second i
remember vividly
i had mono i had mono mononucleosis i
was maybe 12 years old i had mono and my
mother had gout so we were both
bedridden wow yeah i remember i missed
like two weeks of school and i was
watching oprah because my mother watches
oprah all the time and i was watching
oprah in the early 90s or mid 90s and
you know i was my motto dude i was
[ __ ] up and i remember oprah did
was doing some you know one of her talk
shows and she said that she goes she
goes and remember she goes remember that
the money always comes second the
passion comes first the money comes
second if you remember that you'll
always be successful in life and i
remember being a little kid
first you know
whatever fate like those words just got
like burned in my head yeah and that's
very true like now i can sit here and
it's like you know i'm doing okay like
my family has what they want i i have
like stuff beyond my wildest dreams and
it's like because the money came second
exactly i i i i was paying i was losing
money for the first seven years but i
didn't give a [ __ ] because i wanted to
do it but you love doing this i love
doing it i love stand up i enjoy
watching you on stage a lot because you
are very free and you're like yes you
you don't give a [ __ ] in the best
possible way like you give a [ __ ] but
you don't give a [ __ ] and that those are
my favorite comics to watch where it's
kind of like
unpredictable unpredictable but also
like chris has levels to him or like
yeah he can go on
drunk and be hilarious he can go on and
be tight and be hilarious like you have
levels too you're just a funny person no
it's a funny story and the key to you is
you're vulnerable as hell like
especially guys like us we're very rely
on the act we're joking you just open up
up there you let it all out and that
works well because what happened for me
is is when i had you know my my i have
two kids now i have a six year old and a
seven seven month old but when i had my
six-year-old i realized like [ __ ] like
not a negative way not like you know i
don't care whatever passive aggressive
but i kind of like in a spiritual way
was like i don't really care what
anybody else thinks of me other than my
children if my children
look at me and are happy with me and i'm
doing a good job as their dad that's all
that matters so i'll go on stage listen
i'm not a guy none of us are guys i
don't think you can be hateful and funny
there's no way hitler was funny you know
what i mean so it's like so it's like
when people get quote unquote cancelled
or be a real bummer if he was imagining
he's [ __ ] ripped
like like like hitler terrible person
but like he he's pretty witty yeah yeah
i know i know you're like going into the
holocaust like that was a good joke
i killed it he's giving a speech but
thank you just for the weather it's nice
just
yeah but but so i
so i realized like you know like
i'm not a hateful person man like
sometimes my jokes like you know like
i'll talk about race or this or that i'm
like i'm just be it's always coming from
a place of what i want to be funny yeah
so i kind of got over the fact of like
some people might get offended at that
like whatever man like you know i do
jokes about uh i did a joke about a kid
one of my nephews who had a peanut
allergy and all these
people who are parents of children with
peanut allergies were attacking me being
like you're in this [ __ ] like i hope
your kids die and all that i'm like
whatever man like i i don't i don't want
anyone with a peanut allergy to be
affected negatively i'm just making fun
of my truth yeah
[Music]
and that's the problem with the internet
is you react without thinking yeah but i
mean what you're doing is you're trying
to put something positive into the world
your intent is pure yeah these are
people who are like i hope your kids die
yeah take a step back before you write
that take a step back before you write
that in print exactly you psycho put you
they just they just go off emotion they
just go over reaction and just type it's
bad news that's cure that's pure hatred
that's the island yes they're mad at you
for they think you're being hateful
yeah they're actually it's vitriol yes
the best thing i ever did for my um
psyche i guess and it does i don't do
this all the time you know because it's
such an addicting thing social media
it's just like cancer like a cigarette
like i really do think
science will look at the internet and
social media like
you know in 50 years like we look at
like cigarettes you know how science
looked at cigarettes now like yeah they
used to be ads for cigarettes when we
were children there were ads promoting
cigarettes like i think social media's
got like that you know corrosive
property to it but the best thing i
because there's no way around social
media we have to do it right and it
works we have to do it to sell tickets
what i do though now is i post the thing
i need to post for the day and i do not
look at the comments i do not worry if
it's bombing i do not worry if it's
not getting uh enough interaction i
don't do it i say i made the decision to
post this i stand by it whether it
crushes or doesn't and i do not look at
it again i don't care what you said so
hard to do that because it's so hard to
do that though because as comics our job
is to edit based on the response so
that's very difficult i mean like our
acts are like oh i don't care what you
think well then you're a bad comic but
with social media i get what you're
saying it is a different thing you kind
of do have to stand behind stuff it's
going out to the world not a comedy
audience sure so yeah it is different
but i get both of your points you're
both right
well do i agree with him i'm just saying
it's interesting because it is with what
we do it is a different yeah
because my whole thought is like my
whole thought has been like
you know having kids i'm like
what am i gonna do sit here and obsess
over comments or not it's like i i i got
to feed my kid man kid
i got to push my kid in a swing like i i
i can't i don't care what you have to
say because also the truth is is
i believe and this is again not just
comedy
you know
to comment positively or negatively on
anything
is a psychotic kind of person like i
agree 95 percent of people don't just
discuss positive comments well positive
is good we love you guys in the youtube
thank you well youtube's different i
mean like on instagram it's like you
know i comment on you guys like people i
know like this is amazing whatever but
it's like if i don't know you're a
complete stranger to comment ain't
anything on me is like crazy where it's
like even the people who message you and
like hey you know you've helped me
through a tough time and blah blah blah
i appreciate it it's all no i appreciate
it it's all beautiful i appreciate it i
do appreciate it but you have to
understand like even that is a level of
a mental ill like you don't want to
interact with that you don't want to do
that at all because
uh listen the 1975 are a band that i
love they've helped me through breakups
they've helped me through i love that
great man i've never once and i have you
know alex edelman is a guy or a friend a
friend of the show i'm sure alex edelman
opens for them knows them personally
right yes i've never once even messaged
them asked for anything because it's
like it's psychotic i don't know them
right if they somehow if i found out
somehow oh they heard this bit of that
but okay fine but it's like they're just
helping me i don't need you to know that
like right but so it's like it's this
thing where i realized about the human
but if they reached out to you wouldn't
you feel good oh 100 i would but they
wouldn't because they maybe they're
associated with they might well that's
the whole thing but maybe they would
what if what if they're like hey i like
your stuff i think they're just a lot of
people too hey uh i loved your thing on
that is that okay yeah that that would
be cool but they're also like an
established band i'm talking you're an
established comic you did the beacon not
really you know kevin's basically you
dude
how many stories this guy this is the
self-hatred this is the guy who does
letterman and those who then goes right
to the village lantern i know and you
know what else i left out australia i
ate 99 cents pizza
that was good pizza by the way i used to
eat those all the time you think new
york's coming back by the way i don't
know if you talked about this before but
don't doesn't it feel alive again now it
doesn't it does it feels almost pre-20
it feels almost 2019.
almost i don't know i don't know about
that i wish
he's the guy who's not taking the train
he's he's driving in that's the problem
why are the trains empty no they're
crazy they're shady right now it's like
the 80s on the train yeah but but but
that but but that means though that it's
going to come back yeah i hope so we're
not going to live like this whose case
we got some good art out of this hey man
think about all the good movies we got
out of new york being a [ __ ] taxi
driver hell yeah look at dog day
afternoon yeah right but hollywood sucks
it's gonna have to be some independent
[ __ ] on an island i watch power
the dog because he's good it's great
yeah great movie dude
this show was started 20 minutes ago the
show we're supposed to be on oh really
like check it out we're all popping into
aria shafir's uh secret storytelling
show
and we might be [ __ ] him so we should
probably wrap this episode up
guys how does this episode come out
i'm not sure plug some days chris okay
go to chris go to chrisdcomedy.com
um i have a theater tour um i have
cleveland detroit indianapolis
denver
um all these places so just go go check
it out uh portland seattle um
it's really las vegas um so go go to
chrisdcomedy.com
if there's curtains up in some of the
venues it's because i'm sponsored from
blinds to go it's not because i'm not
selling tickets ah you're doing fine
thank you i love you all right we'll
jump in an uber and get the hell over to
that no i got my car i'm gonna drive
drunk yeah i'll drive you want me to all
right don't mind i'll do it we gotta
yeah i got sacramento san diego i know
this coming out orlando west palm
columbus uh salt lake uh all that bull
the beacon or hopefully we'll sell out
soon and then we gotta [ __ ]
um
a bunch of other shits coming uh brea
uh houston
dania beach a lot of [ __ ] oh i'm doing
that daniel you did that chris you did
the floor i like dania is it good i had
a good time in daniel man it's uh fort
lauderdale is awesome oh a lot of shit's
coming i like samrol.com but i'm adding
by the day yeah same here mark
normancomedy.com all kinds of fort wayne
indianapolis uh
la jolla
you know raleigh coming up vague not
vegas uh [ __ ] chicago i've been drinking
so uh mark norman comedy out to lunch
check out the netflix i hate myself
um
hey babe chicago too i'm out of chicago
i'm gonna shoot a special there so oh
are you really
exclusive the den
that's the cool stuff you're shooting
another special on youtube yeah you see
he's a [ __ ] monster he puts it out
he's a machine i mean hey man all right
we'll see you heard it here first folks
thanks keep keep drinking patreon get on
it we got new merch check it out go gay
i love you praise allah we'll see you in
hell trump 2024
[Music]
up on the roof like a cob's coming and
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new orleans
this woman doesn't look like i remember
her and i get down in the same
[Music]
[Music]